you wrote as many there are as many
connections in a cubic centimeter in
brain as there are stars in the Milky
Way galaxy so just a tiny little cubic
centimeter and that's a hundred billion
two hundred billion three hundred
billion connections as many stars as
there are in the galaxy and there's all
this crazy way that you know that we
become who we become and this is
everything from the I want to talk about
these experiments cuz I think these are
the things that we typically don't
really realize but and these aren't
sometimes they're not even experiments
they're accidentals there was a the the
group of a hundred and seventy thousand
romanian or rep or orphaned children and
that was that was because of a celibacy
attacks that if you didn't procreate
they wanted to increase the amount of
population there if he didn't procreate
then you would get taxed and they would
go and make sure that you're pro
creating it so a lot of people had too
many kids that they couldn't feed and
take care of and then those kids went
into the orphanages and then they were
deprived before the age of two of these
important social connections and
important just ways that they
cognitively develop and then now we see
a lot of the issues in terms of their
cognition and their social ability and
you wrote about this and it was very
fascinating there's another example
after there's someone hit but do you
what do you look yeah it's just it's
it's critically important that kids get
things like touch and speech and so on
babies get this because that's how they
essentially the human brain drops in the
world kind of half-baked unlike other
you know if you ever see a giraffe get
born or a cow or a dolphin or whatever
you know after thirty minutes they're
walking around or the dolphin is
swimming around and so on but human
babies if you guys have ever seen one
don't do that after a thirty minutes so
the the question is why do humans take
so long to develop compared to every
other species yeah
and it's because of this issue that we
drop out half-baked and that has really
been the secret that's led to our secret
to our species success because what
we're able to do is absorb the culture
around us and specifically absorb all
the learnings that have happened so far
so an alligator now is exact
can alligator a million years ago there
hasn't been sort of a building alligator
literature or science that's that they
can step out on top of but that's what
we get to do but anyway with Romanian
orphans it turned out that there were
too many in these orphanages and so the
thinking that they were being helpful
the people who worked there said look
don't pick them up and don't talk to
them because then they cry more when you
put them down so just don't don't bother
doing that and what happened is this
whole generation of children didn't
develop correctly they've got deep
cognitive problems
so it's been one of these you know
mother nature's cruel experiments where
you get to see the consequences of this
sort of thing and then there's another
really insane in the interesting example
with Whitman who was just a normal guy
cared about his family cared about his
work and then all of a sudden was having
a tumor press against his amygdala in
his brain that caused him right this is
biology that caused him that caused him
to go out and murder his wife and his
wife's mother and then thirteen people
and just again mrs. Witt this is another
whole weekend we'll touch on some of the
more freewill determinism stuff but that
just blows my mind that you can just be
pushed by a tumor into could that kind
of crazy you lose control right so for
those of you don't know Charles Whitman
was the guy who almost exactly 50 years
ago climbed up the tower at the
University of Texas at Austin and did
what was essentially America's first
mass shooting and he murdered lots of
people he murdered 16 and then 39 people
were wounded and it was just completely
random act of violence he was shooting
pedestrians and the people that came to
help them and ambulance drivers that
came to help them
it was his horrible act and right and so
by the time the the deputies got to the
top of the tower we were able to kill
him immediately whatever wanted to know
is who is this guy and it turned out the
interesting part of the story is that
Whitman wanted to know the same yes sir
he and he was extreme you know his high
IQ and articulate and he kept a diary
for a year before this monitoring and
describing
changes that he was feeling in himself
about how he was becoming more and more
angry has angry at this aggression so he
went to a psychiatrist but this was a
1966 and you know there was no brain
scan or anything like that and you know
he talks like hydras he didn't get any
meaningful help there and so yeah he
monitored this whole thing and then he
wrote a suicide donors typewriter the
night before where he said when this is
all over I want an autopsy to be
performed and and that's exactly what
happened that's how they found it too